[Music]
brainwash yourself into thinking
successful thoughts like i mean bro
imagine you're
brainwashed by like bill gates you know
it's thinking more long term
thank you more long term
sup sup welcome to the 10 million dollar
studio i am your host the internet
detective
welcome how you doing get the lambo in
the back guys i'm out of uniform no
no goofy white shirt suspenders today
okay cause i'll do what i want rebel
today we're talking about the
daily routine of a 19 year old seven
figure entrepreneur that's right you
heard me right
the kids are getting younger they're
getting richer honestly back in my day
you know it took us years to get to
seven figures nowadays they're popping
out of the womb writing checks
making bets that's all i'm gonna say now
i'm gonna say this right up front don't
go harass this guy i don't condone
harassment generally but the guy's 19.
he's clearly making a mistake
and we're gonna talk about it but i want
to be clear
that this is made with love love for all
we're not going to be mean we're just
going to talk about the ridiculous
expectations being set for young people
today
they don't think they have to go to
college they think nine to fives are a
scam they think drop shipping is the
only
way yeah i don't know it's a goofy
little world but my point is
be nice to him so that's uh with that
preface out of the way let's
go ahead with it in mind that i'm gonna
be very nice to this guy
hear that guys that sounds like drop
shipping to me just
okay uh testing me already mikey
i'm trying to be nice to you right now
you can't he's riding in a lambo
what does that sound like sounds like
drop shipping to me
hear that guys that sounds like drop
shipping to me yeah
it's gonna be a cringy video i'm just
gonna tell you guys that right okay
so so the very first thing i do you know
besides drinking rain you know not
sponsored no
i can't address that i'm losing brain
cells i actually go for walks every
single morning because i figured when i
go for walks
um i know it sounds like freaking nerdy
and stuff like what am i like a
six-year-old grandpa or something but in
all seriousness like walking and then
you know when
what what it doesn't sound nerdy at all
it's just like what humans do
they've been walking forever babies what
am i a freaking baby like
walking like what are you talking about
you're tweaking off like 300 milligrams
of caffeine like you just get genius
thoughts and like literally like seven
figure ideas
so did i make fun of this guy i
apologize
i didn't realize he was tweaking off 300
milligrams of caffeine
you know warren buffett elon musk that's
their secret all right guys literally as
you can see i have my freaking initials
in here but uh yeah i literally you know
freaking run the hills gang
i'm upset by this but uh yeah i did that
a couple months ago
so you know that just shows that i've
been walking like a [ __ ] i'm
like usain bolt except i'm the walker
no if he pitched this with a little
sense of irony he'd be a comedian
see we have this preconceived idea that
i was taught that you were taught in
school by teachers
on you know how to get rich how to
become successful is by going to college
but in reality my parents my my friends
parents even some of my friends are like
oh shopify making money online and [ __ ]
having your own online store is a scam
okay so this is the most pernicious myth
that i see
it did like get college scam everything
else not a scam right it's a very common
idea
now listen nobody's calling drop
shipping or shopify by itself
a scam people are saying what is being
pitched
is the scam you're saying you're gonna
make a million dollars in six months
million dollars in two years three years
whatever
the truth about entrepreneurship is like
acting act is acting going to la to be
an actor a scam
well no technically not but if you
started a course where you're like
anybody can be an actor just join my
course of how to be like brad pitt
or whatever that's a scam right because
that's obviously not true obviously
acting is huge risk you got to be a
combination of lucky
skilled you got to be smart you got to
persevere like
it's true of any kind of you know start
on your own stuff this is why i don't
recommend people go become youtubers
because
most people don't make it it's just the
honest truth is it possible to make a
living
yes with drop shipping with any kind of
youtube stuff all these kind of things
but is this the right career path for
many people no i don't know
see because we're taught this
preconceived idea we're sold this fake
dream
you need to be 50 years old you need to
go to college and i [ __ ] jumped out
of high school bro
at 17 years old i was [ __ ] wearing
hoodies i was going to skate park but i
was still making you know [ __ ]
six figure a month income this guy makes
it really hard to be nice to
no you weren't and stop glorifying
dropping out of high school well i'm not
saying drop out or anything
but like if you truly brainwash yourself
and i'm not saying brainwash in a bad
way but like
brainwash yourself into thinking
successful thoughts like i mean bro
imagine you're
brainwashed by like bill gates you know
it's not being necessarily brainwashed
for the worse
also being part of a stoic ideally you
know stoic
uh is basically anyone who foregoes
present pleasure for future gains
you weren't even patient enough to drop
out of high school and you fancy
yourself
a stoic oh
thinking more long term rather than
thinking more
guys drop out of high school drop out of
college hey we don't need college
scam college scam you know what but i'm
a stoic listen guys this whole idea this
whole
myth i'm not gonna say it never happens
because obviously there's
precocious people right uh but the
there's a huge myth out there that
it's realistic and achievable to hit
success in your 20s
right even in your 20s there's this huge
push like from people like
tim ferriss people like uh dan lok
they're like hey yeah it's normal to
expect that i'm gonna be a millionaire
by the time you know i'm
19 years old right it's ridiculous and
it it makes people feel bad about
themselves but not only that it makes
them buy into dumb courses
and actually drop out of things that
could actually improve their education
like you know high school a couple years
ago i was literally getting all f's
in school and i just told everyone i was
going to become a drop shipper and move
to l.a
oh if you're a parent i'm sure you'd
love to hear that hey mom
dad report cards all lefts again but
it's okay i'm gonna go
sell a course now so i just start with
this youtube channel with the 17
course bro like how can i change other
people's lives because obviously i have
my own businesses and stuff like that
but as a stoic does
you know as a stoic does he works his
life for the better of us
other people not just himself i could
benefit myself but true stoics just like
i read in the book today i mean i've
been living by this principle but like
i'm trying to live together as a
community trying to better the community
you know
no we don't know what you're saying the
communities
[Music]
hey the 17 dollar course whatever ain't
up and nobody
that's the sound of the cops um hey
listen i'm saying this right now okay
because you're like 17
cars it's not the end of the world
stephen that's true it's not not the end
of the world he's a young man
young and is gay but let me say i got dm
by someone on instagram who one of this
guy's coaches reached out to and tried
to
upsell into a thousand dollar courses so
he's got the back in where he's trying
to get people in on the expensive
coaching to afford his life
but i want you guys to know look this
isn't real it's all
fake it's all wwe entertainment
ridiculous
nonsense okay honestly people like this
they've learned that people older than
them
are just faking it till you make it so
they go why can't i when they're 19 and
you know what to be honest they have a
point
this guy's about as qualified as a lot
of the other gurus you see all the time
which is to say not qualified at all so
that's what i want to call out guys i
think when you see a
19 year old flexing it's easier to see
through the ridiculous
kind of transparently vapid philosophy
of oh
college education a scam but you know
what's not a scam
drop shipping that's just not true okay
right
listen he's gonna get his act together
he's young he's learning the game
but if you're gonna make a video like
this
you're gonna get of course called out do
you guys remember the retirement video
this is the one where uh max trubitsky
fake retired and said only two stores
remaining i want to give you a finished
shopify store for only 1995.
the idea was he broke his arms and he
gave some sob story
this is basically that by just a
different guy just a copy of a copy of a
copy
right look at this these eight stores
are exact duplicates of this one that's
generating me around seven
thousand dollars yesterday how's that
any different from max trubitsky
giving away a bunch of stores too for
you know money
but not before i give away 20 e-commerce
brands
to you guys to whoever is watching this
video
brands that we've already built and we
were going to use that are identical in
theme
and products found in logo and color
scheme
does that sound anything like this it
has the same exact
branding the same color schemes the same
products
everything is ready to go we've done all
oh so it's
the same as the other guy right so
what's your excuse for
giving these stores away the hard work
we've done the photoshop we've done the
copywriting
in the past couple months leading
towards this holiday season and you
might be asking mikey is it too good to
be true
why are you giving away these eight
stores for only seventeen dollars
i'll tell you why with a single sound
hear that guys that sounds
wake up and smell the coffee